good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
friday it's
friday friday gotta get down on friday
happy last toast of the year yes wow
guys we made it through 2020 this is the
last toast of 2020 and it's
it's definitely bittersweet it is but um
i'm looking forward to having some time
off you know getting to sleep in
and spend time with the love of my life
theo doctor theodore faceman the doctor
is in
well he's out today you see me now he's
out today
he's out he's really really hurts and
it's different considering it's last
show of the year and he didn't want to
grace us with his presence
well i know that maybe for those who
don't live in new york you saw the
instagram stories of like the snow in
new york and everyone's playing a
different version of
you know it's beginning to look good you
know all that [ __ ] but what you don't
see
is the day after where the duty snow
fills the street we have to all the
trucks drive through it it's like the
color duty brown
you can't get anywhere there's nowhere
there's no curb that's like free
it is so i [ __ ] hate when it snows in
new york i like it in the moment and
then
realistically logistically when you have
to leave your house and there's duty
snow everywhere
it's so un
what's the word i'm looking for here
it's like not livable and it's certainly
not livable when you have a dog
i understand i mean slash of the year
but i understand i understand plus the
salt on the ground like you don't want
to get it between their toes
exactly and we're experiencing that
right now so unfortunately theo couldn't
be here today but that doesn't mean it's
not going to be the most amazing
show-stopping incredible show you've
ever seen in your entire [ __ ]
life
this one goes out to theo i know
somewhere he's watching this one's for
you
this one's for you theo thank you for
making the show like even better than
it's already been
all year you know whether he was
sleeping in the background on a zoom
episode or he was sleeping right here
with his head off or he was being
crushed when we tried to get up
theo you made this toast 2020 what it
was and
we appreciate you and we love you no if
i had to um really attribute like the
majority of the success i mean
this has been a crazy year you know
filled with high highs and
so many lows that like i literally could
lost never leave my house again
um but those highs were really made that
much higher by the presence of this
angel here on earth and that's the oh
and even some of the low points where it
was like you know
literally you never wanted to leave my
bed thea was there so i really never
wanted to leave my body
he makes the lows higher yeah so
anyway theo we love you we see you and
to everyone else watching thank you so
much for going on this journey with us
this year
we know it has not been easy yeah but
it's been another year of fabulous toast
episodes especially in q4 like q4 toast
is
20 20 has been some of the best freshest
toast i've ever tasted i couldn't agree
we've been in two different studios this
year
level three if you count like our zoom
situation so three different studios
um and i'm so glad i feel like we're
landing right on our feet and really
where this was a growth year for the
toast you know a lot of growing pains
yes we have to deal with a lot of um a
lot of trauma you know maybe we should
just rattle through all the drama this
year should we
because i don't want it like i don't
want to start with that no meaning
because i really
sometimes like i forget and then you
like i'll remember something no
how can you forget people are constantly
reminding us because i'm pushing it into
like the back of my brain and then i
remember and i'm like oh
yeah yeah i mean there was so many and
you know i feel like i feel two ways
about like being the canceled queens
that we are
i don't know what just you know i had a
pep in my step this morning where i just
like wanted to talk about it all you
know
um i had two two feelings one it's like
you know i did that [ __ ] and i deserve
like i think probably the lowest point
for me this year was my one tree hill
scandal
um and i feel like i still like every
time i think about it just wanna like
jump out a window like i feel awful
about it like i can't apologize enough
but then i think about you know um us
having dinner right
and then it's like outdoor dinner gate
22. outdoor dinner gate 2020
where we were being we we were accused
of being coronavirus deniers
um and we were so obscenely canceled
within our community and that was just
like such a crazy unnecessary thing that
everyone did
but we survived we survived and just
want to remind you guys
we didn't get covered then we didn't
give it and we still haven't gotten it
so i just feel like that's pertinent to
the situation
what's so crazy and i've been thinking
about this a lot is that um
i haven't had coronavirus i know me
neither and now that the vaccine is here
like i can't get it now like
in the next three months like i cannot
get it like i made it this far i know
i've refused i know well we just can
keep doing what we're doing and taking
the exact precautions that we're taking
because i think that we're doing
something right i think we are too
because we haven't gotten it and being
in the epicenter for nine months and
having gotten
going to work every day and having
gotten it right it's just so crazy that
people accuse us of like now that we can
look at this year at a glance
yeah at a glance um how much like we
were given so much [ __ ] online like
really accused of being coronavirus
deniers
coronavirus super spreaders when we
didn't ever have it and we've been so
careful and we literally have lived
in new york we never left new york yeah
crazy this has just been such a wild
year and you know what i don't even
fault people
for like getting mad at us for crazy
things because you're probably going
through a lot too
right i can't be mad at you you know
what how about a clean slate i forgive
you
if you forgive me okay
i love that and that is has been sort of
just like in the background of the whole
year like you think about the people who
are going so hard against us and it's
like wow you have
not even us just like other people i've
seen the way just like
keyboard warriors going harder than ever
before and it's like on the one hand
calm down on the other hand
you clearly have so much time like
obviously it hasn't been a great year
you
virus has affected you too mentally
emotionally clearly right
so i think we should just all forgive
each other clean slate i'm so willing to
clean say because i have my own fair
share of things that like i need to be
sorry for and i am and i'm not a perfect
person and i've never claimed to be
and i always and this is probably the
thing that annoys me most i'm really
just going in
the thing that annoys me most about like
when people like talk [ __ ] about us
there's like all these things being said
about us the thing that probably the
only thing that really bothers me is
when people say we don't apologize which
is so
not true like i feel like any time i
really feel like i'm
wrong i will always apologize but then
it's like i'm not just going to
apologize because you're mad because i
dinner with my family like
i don't feel like i owe you an apology
if you don't think you did something
wrong and you're not sorry you shouldn't
apologize
and i completely agree with that so
that's always what gets me but
i'm never above apologizing when i when
i know i've done wrong like one tree
hill gate was like probably the worst
thing i've ever done like i literally my
body convulses if i see um sometimes i
end up on one tree hill tick tock like
like of people who are obsessed with the
show and it's so triggering to me to
like remember like the
like the horrible thing that i posted on
instagram when i thought i was like just
being funny and like it was not funny
like
that literally the shame is it when i
scroll tic tac and i see someone from
one tree hill you know the fact that i
know the feeling
when i see someone from montreal's face
like this chill comes over my body and
it's
debilitating like and so that's what i'm
saying like i know that i've done wrong
but i feel as though i've also been
wronged so like
maybe just clean slate for everyone into
2021 like past discretions
for we're forgiven and we forgive we
forget
we forgive for the most part
um okay i think it's like a great place
to go into 2021 and just
a great place to start the show how was
your day yesterday it was so
there was so much snow on the ground
yesterday but i also feel like yesterday
was the day that i spent the most time
like out walking in the street
i had so many errands to do yeah that i
was just like in the snow banks all day
but because i had my moon moons on i was
like
happy about it i was in the snow banks
as well with my snow boots and so it
wasn't terrible but it was really
inconvenient
and i just guess like i haven't been out
and about in a while so many of my local
businesses just completely shut down
like while i was hunkering down in my
apartment for the last two weeks just
trying to be really careful
um to not be exposed and i'm so sad like
yeah it's just walking around was so
upsetting
of course the zara is still there but an
amazing
down com like down coat 89 bucks wow
yeah it was a it was a good
haul i did nice all my local businesses
were gone i did a little shopping too
yesterday it was
very overwhelming it was like nobody in
the stores but there was so much
merchandise
i could barely but i figured out how to
how to find a few things for myself i'm
sure you did nobody really i'm never
worried i almost walked out like
this is too much but i actually really
needed some stuff
so last show of the year i don't want to
start because then it's over because
then it's i
i totally agree and like you're some of
your favorite moments we don't need to
rush into the stories
no because they're so and we only have
the southern charm recap so yeah
so let's talk about this year at a
glance that's my favorite
phrase and then that's also why i
realized by the planner company is
called
at a glance so at a glance r.i.p rip
to my planner this year oh same thing
i've already i've already filed it away
with my
other planners i gotta get a 2021 one
yeah me too but like
i keep all my old planners like in a
drawer and i put the 20 21 in there in
like
october yeah um so at a glance
what would you think uh were some of the
highs of this year
wow i mean we can't underscore all of
the highs that we
participated in before covet hit the
beacon theater
the beacon theater lauren and cameron
from love is blind on the toes
yes that was a real high you know yeah
um
we went to la we we we found a little
way to go to l.a
right before february that was the end
of february yeah i even like i went to
cabo in january so like i was having a
nice time
you know i went to mexico in january i
performed at the beacon theater i
released my comedy special i announced
my book
all in all this was not a bad year to be
girl with no job i'm not gonna lie
yeah then even in kovid we had some
highs we had dr burks on the show
that was a huge honor we had francesca
farago when firajo i called her farago
yeah i don't know like
okay that's fine um when too hot to
handle was like popping off and we got
all the tea i mean that was not this
year like you just cannot convince me
that it was never i know
and then we had zoom toast everyone
those were dark days
remember all my different cups no
every day i had a new cup like that was
like how i would treat myself every
morning like i'm going to use one of my
fancy cups
i know like you really really hated the
zoom toast like i didn't you hated it
more than me
no i hated it more there's no way
because i don't really hate
even though the episodes were like
treacherous to do i never hated not
having to get up and get dressed and put
on makeup and leave the house
yeah but i still would do makeup like it
was less and less right
um no my only thing about zoom toast is
like even if we're like
as best as can be like you just can't
replace this
you know of course the magic how do you
say that
in studio
but then we zoomed toast and then we
moved into our new studio so while we
were zoomed hosting we were dealing with
all the drama from our oldest
let's talk about it today's episode is
going to be titled let's talk about
it people wanted to know why we like
suddenly we moved into that studio in
january and we were
here by june so what happened between
january and june you ask
you girls were evicted from our space
for violating new york city rental laws
because it was using a residential
property for commercial purposes
yeah even though we were fair we it was
fair but we were very clear when we
showed up to tour the place and said hi
we're going to be using this residential
property for commercial use and they
said
okay and the board approved us and
nobody cared no but i think that like
the
the landlord didn't care but then like
the building like saw the show and they
were like yeah
no yeah those are the disgraced queens
they heard that we had dinner
outside with our family during
coronavirus and they kicked his office
yes so we had to move and we were just
also done with the drama like we didn't
want to be in a place where we were like
causing trouble and we weren't
always causing trouble we're not looking
for trouble no and by the way another
huge misconception about us i think that
people think we like live for these like
scandals because we have so many
and that like it feeds our business like
you don't understand i loathe them
they just come to me yeah they are just
always showing up at our door so yes we
were evicted
and so during that time we found this
new studio which we love and everyone
here has been like so warm and kind to
us
because it's a it's an office building
like it's this is a place of business
it's a place of business so they respect
our business so here we do our business
and the trackers for tasha come out and
like there's just so much going on they
feel like it's lively
it adds to the show 100 and so we've
been here since june
july and i think it's it's been going
really well and i feel like finally the
studio
is like this is the studio this is what
it looks like the couches are getting
lower and lower by the way the more i
watch our show the more we look like
elf yeah like will ferrell being huge in
like a tiny land made for
short people 100 and also at this point
like we really can't have guests on the
show
because it shows like how our shows are
so miniature
and so i think eventually once these
couches like sink all the way to the
ground and we're sitting
in the floor we'll get new ones but i
just love the vibe of how it looks like
it's so pliny
and i just feel like the aesthetic is
very calming
i agree and it's very on brand for us
it's it's our old studio but really
revamped with like a interior design
er yeah like only cozy vibes
um so that was that was the tea eviction
anything else happened this year we had
a month where we were doing weekly
episodes which was just
so amazing yeah and we were still not
planning on moving too weekly but just
want to let you guys know we loved it
but keep canceling us maybe we'll get
there
also when we were doing uh weekly
episodes
we were talking about how like this is
the traditional podcasting
schedule everyone does one episode a
week and it's like what do they do for
the rest of the week i know
but you know what that week episode
really sneaks up on you big time
yeah we're like we're gonna have so much
free time next you know it's like
tuesday at midnight we're like we gotta
get to watch seven hours of television
um so it's really been a great year of
course we we joke and we we laugh but
it's been a wonderful year and we really
want to thank
all the people who are still here all
five of you
yeah no seriously thank you guys so much
we
absolutely love we always say this we
love doing the show and we love that you
love it and
i hope that we can just keep loving
each other forever yeah and what's funny
is like this really this year has just
been like kind of the
restructuring of the shows like our
business is different in many ways like
we no longer go live
um we're pre-recorded which i think for
the time that we're living in and
people just really being so hyper
sensitive to content they see online
and um i just think that's for the best
yeah we really still don't really edit
our episodes but i think it's nice to
just have that
you know option option um we no longer
have our facebook groups which honestly
has been such
a weight off my shoulders like
i think that it was a matter of time
whether we ended it or like facebook
ended it like something really horrible
was going to come out of
you know that group of just like highly
you know emotional
charged up people young men and women
and i think that
it's much better now and i think that
although things have changed so much
this year the toast is bigger and better
than ever honestly bigger and better
than ever and you know who has had a
great year not a person
a thing um i don't think you're
seeing where i'm going okay go the
patreon yes content has just been
on point this year we tried to make as
many vlogs as possible and there's just
so much like good stuff in there because
really content was king this year
yeah and i think that patreon more than
ever when it felt for so many people
that there were like very few safe
spaces on the internet
the patreon facebook group and the
patreon like website
has been that for the toast community
it's a very safe warm welcoming place
yeah so head over to patreon.com the
morning toast because it's
the best place to be and it's a great
way to support your favorite gals
patreon.com slash morning toast
okay i feel like i've reviewed the year
and i'm ready to put this year
in a box in a drawer and not open it
again
in a box beneath my bed
is all the scandals that i never read
a few summers back literally literally
um we're putting this here to bed after
this
2020 see ya no honestly like starting
january first do not talk to me about
anything that happened in 2020 i don't
know her i will not address it like
yeah imperfect right and i think that
this story is so big and it keeps
getting bigger that there's
absolutely no way that they're not
talking about beverly hills which
they're filming right now
there's absolutely no way right but
there was a lot of talk about her being
like demoted to friend of housewife um a
while ago but i feel like if that even
were the case
she's not now yeah she's back up she
circled back yeah yeah circled back by
eod
so we'll keep you posted on the trial
but there's a lot of news there
and i'm just really curious i'm not
really that interested in like the
legalities of it all i'm just now
curious of like
how does this affect my viewing of the
real housewives is erica poor what
happens to the plane you know
yeah that's what i want to know yep okay
next story
pete davidson is removing all of his
king of staten island
still doing press for that movie that
was like the first quarantined movie and
it's still like number one on itunes
because literally nothing else came out
yeah i don't i didn't watch that one i
saw big time terrible
it's the same movie i feel like i saw it
same exact moment um a film except one
of them had machine gun kelly which one
big time adolescent so it was obviously
better because we stand
mgk in this house yeah a film critic
broke the news when he tweeted a
screenshot from the event saying just
attended a makeup chair to cover them
oh well oh that's why it would be easier
to quote get them burned off what roles
is he doing that doesn't let him have
i don't know on snl it's like the the
hair and makeup is not
because it's three-minute sketches it's
not that involved that they would need
to cover his
tattoos if he was like you know being a
businessman and like how to work and
what does that mean for those who don't
speak hebrew it's not it's not
respectful this is not respectful i
agree and it's a
as we say this is a shonda like and this
is a private family matter yeah vanessa
feels the same way frivolous disgraceful
and unimaginably hurtful i can't even
imagine
how hurtful no this is this is something
that it's a private family matter that
should be handled as such
in you know the private family quarters
yeah and like
to not only make it so public is so
hurtful but then to sue like
why is it all about money you know what
i mean like that's terrible i mean
justice for vanessa bryant to be going
through this after what she went through
is so horrible and to have it come from
your mother i mean
so hard that's sad very sad very very
sad
i just she's one of the people i'm like
always thinking of you know what i mean
like i just hope she's okay
i feel like she has a lot of support
around her it's but they're just some
things that
you don't do yeah no but i she has and
i'm so i was talking about
kobe and gigi like she has so much
support around her which
is helpful but not ever going to bring
them back yeah
and also i can't believe that was this
year like that's one of those things
like
you know where you were when you heard
about like 9 11. you know i remember
where i was when i heard about kobe
bryant
where were you um it was i was in my bed
obviously because that's always where i
am
and i heard it and there are always
these like weird
you know hoax yes fake death stories
like
coming out like i remember um when we
were kids there was a remember that
cheyenne from the mtv show there was
like a
hoax that she died like they they always
do this and
so at first you don't believe it but
then when it comes from tmz it's like
oh no and it takes like a day to fully
process it and i called ben because he's
like the biggest kobe fan and
i thought i would be breaking the news
to him because i'm like he doesn't know
anything like he doesn't follow pop
culture like
i thought that i would have to like
break the news to him and he knew and he
was like
in [ __ ] denial like on the street
like left work he needed a minute like
he was outside like
literally having a panic attack wow
crazy where were you
i was also in bed it wasn't even
quarantined
it was a sunday we had no excuse yeah
okay well um next story is some actually
some really happy news
the bachelorette zach clark reconnects
with the bank teller who made the call
that saved his life
did you see the episode where he
explained to jesus on his one-on-one
he talked about his struggles with
addiction and how he
you know hid his lowest point by writing
um fraudulent checks and a teller at the
bank
recognized that you know this was not a
kosher situation and called his dad
and so he went back to the bank and met
with the angel
he calls her that saved his life he said
on august 28
2011 i walked in the into the pnc bank
in camden new jersey and i met my angel
rhonda jackson
rhonda didn't know me didn't care what i
looked like and didn't judge me
she just knew that i needed help as i
tried to cash a forged check
so i could get some quick money and keep
getting high rather than call the cops
rhonda called my dad
whose name was on the check as the
account owner three days prior i had
stolen a handful of checks
yeah and so he posted a picture to his
instagram of him and rhonda oh my god
stop i [ __ ] love zaxy that is really
really really really cute
um and if like that's so interesting
that like
i don't know oh also i finished the
flight attendant i want to talk about it
um i that's so interesting that he like
remembers
her even though like she technically
like turned him into you know what i
mean like yeah
but he considers it like a blessing yes
a major
beautiful story he said that she
remembered the day vividly and we hugged
like we had known each other forever in
a world that is filled seemingly with so
much apathy
rhonda jackson taught me a valuable life
lesson always treat people with love
always believe and always do the right
thing oh god i'm literally going to cry
this is i know i have chills you never
know whose life
you might be saving thank you rhonda for
saving my life there are no coincidences
oh my god i literally have chills that's
so sweet
i love this story and now i love zaxy
even more i know and i wonder if they
would have reconnected
if not for the bachelor obviously if he
had posted this instagram and hadn't
been on the bachelor like no one would
care no one would have seen it yeah but
i wonder if like she saw him on the
bachelor and
maybe him tell his story i just think
this is such an amazing story and it
teaches a very valuable lesson like
treat people with love and just look out
for others
look out for your neighbors yeah you
know what
i feel like in this year i don't mean i
don't have neighbors but just like
watching a lot of tv and like seeing
what's going on in the world i feel like
this year has really
really also been the year of like your
neighbors i feel like those people who
have neighbors really relied on their
neighbors this year for like different
things you know
yeah well i feel like for me since
getting a puppy i spent a lot of time
just like
on the street in the building yeah and
i've really come to know my neighbors
and
there's such like a puppy community out
there that i didn't even know like now i
know some of the other dogs in
neighboring buildings and their owners
and you know everyone's always asking
like even if they see me they're like
how's bruno and i'm like oh wow like
they would have just passed me
by like bruno is really connecting me to
my community i'm not even like [ __ ]
no no that sounds awesome
he really really is and now like i just
i have so many familiar faces like
there's yeah
by the way i came into jackie's house
and she literally had like this bag of
like treats and like jackets and i'm
like what is that she's like
oh there's another cavalier in the
building and he grew out of his uh
harness
and gave it to her so we gave it to
bruno or like sometimes i'll like
take bruno out in the morning i'll see
someone walking to work and then when i
take him out at night like i see the
person
that's crazy yeah there's like this one
guy who i'm a schedule who i always see
maybe he leaves when it's time for the
toast like he's a toaster oh for
sure i mean that sounds so nice i
literally am the only person who lives
in my entire building
in my entire block um and i've never
seen another human being but my doorman
love theo oh my god of course they do
because he's so [ __ ] perfect
yeah and so they're really like his
uncles oh
yeah but he doesn't have any neighbors
and neither do i and we like live in a
sad place
that's nice with no other people you
have to move to my building because the
cavalier community is like
strong how many cavaliers are in your
building now now there are three
cavaliers in my building
and four one theo moves in um so wait so
funny so i have a
an alert on street easy for your
building because like if new
apartments come up i wanna i'm like be
the first one
and this apartment came up and i'm like
i don't know if it's for me
it was your old apartment no i know zack
showed it to me last night that it made
it onto street easy that's so funny
that's funny
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story oh and they listed it for
less than what you were paying i mean
does that bother you
sign of the times no yeah i would have
been chalked if they didn't like what
world are you living in sign of the
times
um are you ready for a fifth and final
story yes ma'am cause carrie underwood
got the best gift for christmas from her
husband
what cows wow that is a good gift
carrie underwood's husband mike fisher
got her cows for christmas quote
they make me so happy she said he she
said he got me cows which is what i
wanted they're my favorite animal i love
them
she doesn't plan on doing anything she
doesn't want them for any purpose she
said
just to love them yeah you know i'm
gonna say something really crazy
okay i actually had this thought
yesterday when
um i was cleaning out my fridge and
there was like this
like gallon of milk in the back that
literally i don't know why we have milk
like i don't really drink milk
um sometimes for my cereal so i poured
it out it was like completely full and
it felt so wasteful
and i just kind of had this moment where
i'm like
i don't think i'm gonna have milk
anymore why because it's like really sad
for the cows
um it's like painful aren't
they i i'm not familiar with milk no but
i'm sure
i've been aren't cows made to be milk
yes but like the way that they overdo it
and like i
start them at young ages and like
multiple times a day it's like
it's really not good okay well i think
if you like own a farm and you're not
like pasteurizing your own milk and
selling it to grocery stores and like
you want some milk
sure go milk your cow but i think like
the way it's like
streamlined like and it's so crazy like
it's their whole like they just get
milked all the time and it's like really
painful and i don't think it's done well
and
i think i'm gonna stop drinking milk
because it's really easy for me to give
up because i literally never drink it
but i'm just gonna stop buying it okay
but like don't put the milk up in the
shower
it's half and half don't put the farmers
out of business half and half is half
half and half of two different kinds of
milk so it's what i just learned
but why don't you just have almond milk
because it's not dairy
sure like it comes from almonds i just
think i think this might be my journey
to veganism
okay i'm not i'm talking and that
includes chicken
well no i'm going to be a chickaterian
where i don't eat anything except for
chicken i can't
this is the thing it's either tacos it's
either the chicken or me
because if i don't eat chicken i'll die
what about tacos with chicken
ground chicken okay okay good luck i'm
thinking about it i just feel like
the the farmers have had a rough year
too like don't put the milk in the
shower no i'm not but if the farmers
could just be nice to the cows like that
would really mean
i'm sure they love the cows so much like
harry underwood
yeah great segue
but i also don't know that much about
like milk culture
you know and on the industry i'm just
saying like i've been seeing some really
convincing like
vegan propaganda where i'm tic tac like
everywhere like i just see it everywhere
and it's starting to get to me you know
okay but i don't know if that's
propaganda like is it real i don't know
uh don't quote me on any of this i just
like i have to do my research but they
planted a seed
they planted a seed sometimes it's
important you can
grow um thank you so much for those five
stories jackie they were [ __ ] handy
yeah they were interesting um and now
we're gonna do our southern
southern southern recap our southern
charm recap brought to you by liquid iv
cooler weather makes it easy to miss
signs of dehydration like overheating
and perspiration
which means it's even more important to
keep your body properly hydrated
and with one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water you get two to three
times the amount of hydration as plain
water
flu season often lines up with our
holiday plans but liquid iv can help
support your immune system with
increased hydration and essential
vitamins given the pandemic and given
the fact that it's the winter and
sometimes it's harder to
realize that you might be dehydrated
it's never been a better time to try
liquid iv first of all i
i cannot drink water like it's just like
i have this this
like it's sticking to the maniosis it's
a really serious disease um and so i
really just can't drink water plane so
i'm always like trying different things
to put in my water
and liquid iv tastes so good and then it
literally makes like the one bottle that
you're drinking
basically like three in terms of
hydration so it's really encouraged if
you have a hard time drinking um
water or if you just really want to be
hydrated liquid iv's best-selling
hydration multiplier
which is what i use now has three
flavors guava watermelon and apple pie
one serving of liquid iv provides the
same hydration as drinking two to three
bottles of water alone
it contains five essential vitamins more
vitamin c than an orange
and as much potassium as banana they're
way healthier than
sugary sports drinks and they contain no
artificial flavors preservatives
and they have less sugar than an apple
they're totally made with clean
ingredients they are non-gmo vegan
free of gluten dairy and soy thank god
they're vegan i can still have them
they're so effective because of their
cellular transport technology
and they're on a mission to change the
world their company has donated over 6.7
million servings globally
and in response to cobin 19 their
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans
active us military
and over 3 million servings in total
have been donated so far so you can know
that your purchase is going a long way
because we are taking
care of the people in our country who
need it the most liquid iv is available
nationwide at walmart in the beverage
section or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com and use
the promo code toast at checkout
again that's 25 off anything you order
when you use the promo code toast at
liquidive.com
get better hydration today at liquid
iv.com promo code
toast love it okay oh and before we wrap
up um
this is probably the last time in 2020 i
can promote my book and i feel like we
should make it a good one
okay you know what why don't you say
something nice about the book jackie i
feel like
you're hurting your feelings you've
never said anything nice about her
really read the back
read back she's just kidding you say
something should i read my
my shorts this is what this is how i
felt about claudia's book
much like the author herself this book
is hysterical
and smart but might also make you cry
since the day she was born i have been
claudia's number one fan
and 26 years later that has not changed
really aging me
the admiration and pride i have for her
has only intensified
and upon reading her story you will feel
similarly
wow that was really beautifully done
like and you really came up with that
really quickly when i asked you for it
like it's like so you've been waiting
your whole life to say you know
yeah no it's just like it fell out of me
i i just i it fell out of you i write
how i feel
you're and you're such a beautiful
writer because that's really profoundly
written so thank you for doing that by
the way yeah i just
think i mean like i mean you're really
the writer girl very true
girl with no job is my book it's called
girls no job the crazy beautiful life of
an instagram thirst monster
and i did a little chapter recap on my
instagram last week i've started to do
like weekly reveals
um this week i am going to reveal the
back the rest of the blurbs but if you
missed the chapter recap allow me to
recap for you chapter one my first
period
okay that's a joke from friends um
chapter one
is you know i really should memorize
this let's see if i can do it all
chapter one
is introduction well there's the
introduction and then chapter one
wow i'm really like calling myself out
chapter one wouldn't it be starting from
the beginning
yeah i want to say it's my childhood a
star is born yeah
chapter two is uh
college you know it's like nobody asked
no i know but it's like is it crazy not
to know like you're
um i don't think so but like you're
putting yourself on the spot no anyone
i'm like really exposing myself so like
let me just get my um well
yeah now you have to find it but i just
wanna everyone's like she didn't write
her own book
she doesn't know that she's that's next
that's also a conspiracy about me but
that's okay like people have said way
worse things about me but i did write my
own book if you care and it's really
good
she did you can literally hear your
voice in it yeah 100 like
no one else could have written it i'm
just like having a hard time finding
this
dog i'm like really out here exposing
myself but i'm gonna find
it just give me a second oh will you
just forward it to me please
thank you i am just give me a minute
everyone
just talk amongst yourselves take your
time um
yeah so what's new with you there's
always gonna be another
mountain i'm always gonna wanna make it
move always gonna be an uphill battle
sometimes you're gonna have to keep
going ain't about how fast i get there
ain't about what's waiting on the other
[Music]
perfect timing i think that sounded
really good that was actually pretty on
on key thank you all right here are the
chapters for those wondering what the
book might be about
versus introduction and actually i
didn't give the um the chapter titles
maybe this will be like a nice reveal
chapter title one is born thirsty that's
all about my childhood funny
things you know you might i mean you
might think like what was claudia like
when she was growing up but jackie can
attest that like i actually have a
pretty embarrassing like childhood
um because i was such a little nut job
and there's a lot in there that you
definitely don't know about me a lot of
my friends
when i send it to them they're like i
had no idea what was going on at home
like so funny porn thirsty she really
needed some milk
stop chapter two a career is born this
is when i started my career um at my
time at nyu just a lot about you know
being a college gal and then it growing
and like
having to be like an influencer at nyu
which was really
so challenging and really embarrassing
at points third was girl with no
full-time job which is when i graduated
college and unlike my peers decided to
not get a job
and work on influencing full-time which
is not what it was today and it was
really embarrassing
it sounds like this is a book of
embarrassment girl with no
embarrassments
chapter four in search of a nice jewish
boy with no job this is all about how i
met ben my very short-lived dating life
before ben
my you know life being married to men
and then you know the formative
experiences that happened to me
as a child as it pertains to men that
really shaped the woman i am today
um number chapter six oh no chapter five
is chubby stubby and fabulous
which is all about my journey with body
image i don't know if you guys know this
jackie and i did attend a fat camp
growing up and i do uh you'll read about
in the book blame it for all my problems
um and that's just a chapter on body
image and what it's like to be fat and
famous
that should have been the top chapter of
the title it's so much better than
famous
um chapter six is will all the real
stands please stand up this is my
journey into being obsessed with pop
culture and like
how how i got here like why am i so
obsessed with like the logistics of
being a celebrity
chapter seven is when the fan becomes
famous so this is like jackie and i have
really
so hard not to talk for you in the book
like i'm talking for you right now
chapter seven is like it's just because
i'm here
the dynamic of like being so obsessed
with pop culture that like you actually
become like well
known for being a fan famous for being a
fan and then you get your own fans and
like what's that dynamic like and like
is it kind of toxic
chapter eight is you're either going to
love me or hate me in the words of
danielle stab and this is all about
cancel culture this is probably the
chapter you're gonna
like open up the book and skip to it's
page 173 if you're looking for it
and it has all the questions you want to
answer like i know everyone wants to
know like
what happened on the day that you were
canceled this is a i give you a play by
play of the actual day
do you talk to your mom it's all in
there so buy the book if you care
page 173 chapter nine from canceled to
comedy
this is picking up the shambles of my
life and trying to re-uh
you know start my career and then just
assign deciding to do comedy and how i
started that
and then ended up at the vegan theater
and then chapter 10 is oppositional and
defiant the conclusion which will make
you cry
yeah that's my story the the thesis
where she's landed on all of these
things what i've learned
yeah so that's the book again
girlwithnowjob.com book is the link
check it out all the places that you can
purchase the ebook the audiobook and the
print version are all there you can
support local bookstores
by using the bookshop link or you can
buy from amazon or barnes and noble
check it out i would appreciate the
support thanks um
i feel like that was the best it ever
went in terms of i'm just telling people
what they want to know like
yeah i know what you're looking in the
book and i put it in there because i
want to sell books
yeah i put it there check it out great
um okay southern charm
yeah kind of boring oh you know what i
felt i thought it was boring sure but
like when it was over i was kind of like
sad i was like oh i actually could have
watched more of that
okay um again i just continually like
can like refuse to just get past like
the weirdness that is patricia ultra
hosting a bunch of 35 year old men in
her backyard and it's like she couldn't
have her boys dinner because of covid
and it's like
the minute she's allowed to have people
over there she's the first thing she
does dinner and it's so weird and then
she's also like
stay away from me but it's like you
invited all these people over to your
house if you don't want them near you
don't invite them over like
it is such a weird dynamic and then i
was really like trying to be
you know give her the benefit of doubt
and be like okay maybe they just need a
place to film and they need a sort of
party but then like
why not invite the girls yeah it's so
weird
her presence on the show is just
becoming weirder and weirder and i
thought that like austin had
the greatest read yes of all time when
he was like wow has patricia never been
in love has it always just
always been about money and i was just
like and that was a fair assessment it
is so
shady because she's so old school yeah
um no because she's always advocating
for madison
not to follow her heart but to like
follow right the
the money yeah um and i think i agree
like patricia's presence on the show is
getting weirder and weirder and weirder
and it felt really weird when leva
called her
because how does leva even know her yeah
it's only because of the show and it's
like you gotta come kiss the ring
yeah it just felt so weird and i never
really understood or
like appreciated patricia's presence on
the show and don't get me wrong i do
think patricia's life is very
interesting and i don't
dislike seeing her with michael and her
butler and the inside of her house it's
all there is
a patricia show but to have her as like
the puppet master for all of these young
people
and however so involved in their lives
and so mean
i it never ceases to like make me
be like what is she doing here yeah and
especially when over the years like
her involvement has resulted in like
people's like lives being really like
katherine like really being
affected yeah and now let's talk about
the catherine of it all her and danny
just like their friendship just not
being
it um and part of me i feel torn because
i've always felt like their relationship
was really weird like
danny was always this doormat for
catherine and like always there for her
unapologetically and it's like we all
knew that like how are you just figuring
it out that your relationship is toxic
yeah and so it's like okay i'm glad
you're figuring it out
um and then you can understand why
catherine's confused is that like what's
changed
no this is kind of like bethany and
carol where it was like
this was the friendship and like then
you started questioning it and it's like
just stop it was good when it was
that's how it was you know yeah no i'm
happy for danny that she's standing up
for herself
we all knew what it was i thought it was
like weird like how much of a dormant
you were for the last five years yeah
but like also why can't you try just
like not being a doormat that doesn't
mean that you don't have to be friends
with someone
but like maybe like standing up for
yourself and like not taking [ __ ]
instead of just like writing off the
friendship completely right and you know
before the episode um they played last
week's episode like secrets revealed
where they put those incredibly
stupid irrelevant fun facts in a box on
the left
and when they were talking about danny
it said the dumbest thing it was like
she really was mad that catherine didn't
reach out to her during the whole monkey
emoji thing
um because she thought it meant that
like you know
danny's opinion on racism like didn't
matter it was just so stupid and it's
like
you can be mad at katherine danny has a
lot of things she can be mad at
catherine about like their friendship
really is unfair
but i'm not understanding like this hill
you're dying on of like catherine not
reaching out to you
for as long as we've known catherine
it's like she never shows up she never
answers her phone like that's who she is
she disappears for days at a time
so i don't think she was necessarily
like not reaching out to you but she
only got mad when she found out that
catherine reached out to leva
yeah whereas like love is obviously like
this really smart person who gave
catherine really good advice yeah so i
don't know why she's like
so mad about her reaching out to level
danny has a lot she could be mad at her
for but i don't know why this is the
thing that like got her
to this place yeah i feel that i i i
don't see it either maybe next week they
have another conversation
what looks to be a fabulous beach party
yes um so maybe we'll get more clarity
around that i'm actually really excited
for that episode and then it looks like
austin and leva
are go at it on a boat yeah which is
crazy yeah i felt bad for austin at the
end of the episode
because he just loves madison so much
and like
aside from like being you know like a
11 year old he's just never really done
anything like bad no they're just a
mismatch and i think
what patricia said which is what nobody
focuses on but really seems to be like
the heart of the matter
is that he's not ready to be a
stepfather you know and so we could talk
about the fact like everyone always
makes it about like
he's not there in his business right
he's not mature enough but the end of
the day
all of those things come back to the
fact that if he wants to be with madison
he needs to be
a parental figure and he's not ready to
be that person so that's true i think
that
that more needs to be made of that
because making it about the other things
just makes austin feel like a piece of
[ __ ] and like and when she
say in his confessionals like i know i'm
good enough for madison it's like
yeah why is everyone just telling him
straight up like you're not good enough
for her
you're never gonna be yeah she needs to
do better when it's like he seems like a
actually a really
decent person i agree maybe he parties
too much and maybe he lets like the show
he gets carried away yeah the same in
the celebrity and i think it's really
hard not to
especially like in a town like
charleston it's small and
you know it is they're always it's just
too it is what it is yeah
um i think that everyone is super hard
on him when he's
when he has like a good heart i agree um
and
as what i said last week of like being
obsessed with madison and pringle i'm no
longer there
something about pringles starting to
bother me when he was like
hitting on the bartender and then also
like when and talk to the guys like in
front of her face like about how she's
like a smoke show
yeah i just like if you use the word
smoke show it's going to be a notebook
the whole thing was like disrespectful
and it's like oh so you're just like
obsessed with
every world that you see it's not
madison it's just like her looks
i didn't pick up last week or they
didn't show the footage where he
complimented her
thighs i didn't pick it up i thought he
said
eyes and i think there's something
deeply problematic and i can't really
get into it but there's something deeply
problematic about complimenting a
woman's size i'm sorry like it's weird
and he's just starting to look so dirty
like take a shower i i'm like over him
yeah i don't ship him in madison no me
neither even if she madison needs a
businessman bo
it always comes back to that it always
comes back to it well she's the
businessman girl
this is this girl bo hmm i've got to
work on this one
she's a businesswoman special yes yes
there you go
oh my god that's so funny by the way i
have been making so many cameos like
literally it's the most fun thing ever
and it's just so interesting like what
people gravitate to
um in terms of toasty lingo and everyone
just asks for me to call like their best
friend and their girlfriend beautiful
stunning and smart oh
that's so nice you guys are nice friends
it's really sweet so book me on cameo
thanks
um other than that i thought it was a
good episode
and i was just like so weirded out that
it all revolved around this party at
patricia said she seemed to like not
want to have like no one asked you to
have it
and why not invite the girls no it was
weird and it was raining is keeping the
gender
separate it's weird she's just so old
school and and you were saying last week
how southern charm has always been like
this boys club
and the puppeteer of southern charm is
patricia she's the one who's made it
this boy's club forces
these traditions like traditional gender
roles
and i think she's not a good influence i
completely agree
like i'm just i'm every week i just feel
like that's the my takeaway
yeah it's the patricia is weird child
yeah and i think it's because
well i think there's a number of reasons
why she has such a big
influence on the show but i think one
like because whitney's an executive
producer
and i think he's taken himself out of
the show because i think like when he
put himself in it
people didn't like him and i don't think
he could take that yeah he was like i'm
gonna remove myself and like mom people
love you
so be a big part of the show and also
because of the house and like
the michael of it all and it's also
fabulous they need that
i don't know i just i think they're two
separate shows on the count of three say
your favorite southern charm cast member
okay oh wait hold on
oh i mean i have so many but i'm just
like three
ready okay three two one craig
yeah i [ __ ] love him yeah and he's
just out here giving everyone really
good advice i thought that the
conversation he had with madison was
like a really nice
and not like it was a nice thing to do
obviously if austin like saw it he would
be upset but
it was in austin's best interest and i
think
that craig is a is a good person i agree
he is
i don't think he is i agree he's a nice
boy yeah i've never seen him like be
intentionally mean to me neither and
he's oh he's been like
railed on and made fun of more than
anyone like even the fact that
shep named his dog good boy craig which
is so rude and then craig and then shep
walks around his house and a t-shirt
that says craig is my lawyer
and then he just got so much [ __ ] for so
long about the pillows and then the bar
exam and like
now i just feel like he's in a good
place like did you see on um
i guess they did it last week too but i
didn't see but on bravo if you're
watching on cable
on the left side they had a little qr
code that popped up and it's like
you swipe this qr code to buy craig's
pillows so his pillows are actually like
legit they're selling them on shop by
bravo he's on hsn
like sewing down south he came on our
show and he has like a huge partner that
guy the thomasville company which is
like a southern merch company
like he's doing really well he is doing
really well and and i just didn't see
that for him
yeah no i'm proud of him and i i love to
see him i feel like even though the guys
are still like always you know
taunting him like there's less to taunt
him and it doesn't get to him anymore
he's like
secure in himself yeah but i do still
think shep naming his dog craig is like
so
weird yeah um that's all we got for you
guys anything you want to say before we
wrap up the
last show of the year
thank you so much for if you've made it
to the end of this episode
thank you for everything yeah you guys
we love doing the toast
we hope that it has brought you joy yeah
in a really really hard year
yeah and when you guys message us and
like tell us what it's meant to you you
know whether it's a commuter
you're working um on the front lines and
just the toast is a little companionship
every day like that's why we do what we
do
yeah and it makes all the other stuff
that comes along with it worth it
honestly
just to make one person's day a little
easier a little brighter a little filled
with laughter
little steamy vibes like that's all
we're trying to do here
in here and i think those vibes and make
your days feel like a little more
comforted and that's so important to
remember like not
you know we live in a really difficult
world especially this year with so much
going on
and you know not everything is that
serious like you die
you and i wake up every day with the
just one goal of like making people
smile
i know that a lot of people save the
podcast like for their commute or for
whatever and that means a lot to us and
i think the fact that this is
the toast has become so ingrained in
people's routine and when we don't
when we're not here like people miss it
like that means so much to us and that's
why we do it
and we really hope that this year has
been you know as easy as it could have
been for everyone and that the toast
was helpful in alleviating some of the
pains of 2020 and hopefully
when we see you guys on january 4th yeah
i think so
2021 like it's a brand new world new
world two discs no no you're setting too
high
no i'm not i'm not no you are new world
to this
we're just we're going into 2021 with
optimism
and we're excited to see you all there
and if you are feeling rdh this is the
last show of the year
there is new content on patreon.comtoast
and we will be putting out
new episodes weekdays next week so that
to fill that 10 30
a.m void yeah you can head over to
patreon.com morning toast and when you
sign up you get access to our entire
catalog so that's like over 200 episodes
so there's really a lot of content for
you
during our little break but i'm hesitant
to wrap up is there anything we didn't
say i just
i really want to express the gratitude
jackie and i feel for everyone who tunes
into this show like it really
makes our day and i hope it makes your
day yeah and to everyone who works on
our show and all of our partners and
at audioboom everyone we love you thank
you for supporting the toast
even when it wasn't easy yeah
and all of our tnn shows always you can
head over there if you're looking for
some more content too
we just love everyone that we work with
we love everyone who listens to the show
and and we love each other thanks cloud
for another great i love
you are you going to touch me oh the
little ow
oh god sorry i got a little rough and i
draw my chewy bar wrapper i think it's
time to wrap up okay
love you guys so much thank you again
for being toasters i hope you've enjoyed
this wonderful year of shows
i think we did about like 230 shows more
i think it's like or 260 plus like five
patreons at 12 that's like 72.
no about 300 episodes yeah that's crazy
that's [ __ ] scary we should stop
talking
no and i can't believe we haven't run
out of [ __ ] to talk about yet the day is
coming don't worry no no but it really
doesn't because like
the world turns the world keeps turning
and then there's just new stuff
we love you guys pick up a new hobby and
there's new stuff you know yeah i'm
definitely going to take up knitting
again thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning chose the
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast five stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching
us on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have radio cat box all the places so
wherever you listen to podcasts find out
some morning chosen leave a five star
review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are we hope you
have an amazing amazing holiday season
please stay safe
merry christmas to you and your families
take some time off it's been a hard year
and just enjoy and relax we love you
love you
[Music]
bye
you